hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
Don cases five diamond cases I just
introduced Casey Spivey by the way we're
gonna watch a sketch video but she does
sketches our own to you blonde jokes
YouTube channel go check it out as soon
as you can
woman in comedy it's happening it's
happening one culture and they're
nature's woman I gotta be funny for the
men now anyway I just showed her a video
I used to watch these guys all the time
at least reacted and I still watch them
on my own time raka raka I saw they put
out this video a Harry Potter versus
Star Wars too but a second video ever
saw for them was Harry Potter versus
Star Wars when the most popular videos
and I just showed Casey it off camera
she was hard time they made a sequel
after all this time I was like well we
gotta watch this immediately Casey are
you ready already
yeah yeah it was a video t monetization
did monetization then music copyright
ads I'm overlapping it so that way a
wizard wages war on a Jedi
just as the battle looked to be over an
unlikely fell appears
[Music]
Wow they picked it up right wow this is
crazy if you're gonna write out
[Music]
oh my god Harry lip
oh wow the budget
whoa oh my god holy cow
[Music]
[Music]
they have made money oh sweet and sad
some girl on a bikini
she's a sorting hat
[Music]
brothers versus
[Music]
Wow oh man
oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hi
[Music]
[ __ ] is wearing a branded t-shirt
Oh No
[Music]
hell yeah he's familiar brands
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh interesting you could see the movies
they're liking the bank Big Lebowski Inc
is here
Wow I got to give a round of applause
out of those awesome I thought that's
really great now you can see the nose
hair popping out of his nostril there
I'm from Iraq Iraq for such a long time
and their sketches have definitely
gotten like bigger and they've gotten
crazier and more violent vogue or
whatnot it's like clearly they've upped
their game since the first Harry Potter
versus Star Wars yeah I'd love to hear
your thoughts because it's crazy for me
to go back to their video from 2014 yeah
when they were just like well no this is
fun for them then to code here I was so
impressed with oh they're picking this
up immediately from the last one yeah
it's not just something like random
sketch of just let's redo it or do
something else that was immediately
picking up and then they went
exceptionally bigger with some practical
stunts some great VFX in here and
watching that growth to me personally I
actually find my pretty inspiring so
what do you think Casey Spivey that was
insane and I feel like from the first
video I watched to this video they kept
the same sense of humor which I thought
was nice because they didn't just get
lost in the CGI of everything they kept
the jokes which is the whole point and I
think that's great I loved how they
mixed the costumes are clearly from
Halloween you know it's like they didn't
try to up the ante on any of their
costumes or anything like that like they
kept true to what was originally funny
they just added more of it yeah
instead of trying to completely upgrade
I thought that was really smart a really
well done well that's part of the charm
I think of a lot of their short films
and sketches I think that's what makes
the bigger moments so effective yeah
because clearly they're doing this very
DIY I mean sure they have a sponsor from
Skillshare hitter a special link again
which that serveth if it's not like
positive for skilled shooters like yeah
we're gonna fund your whole super fun
you know that's not what that is it's so
for them to do that they still have the
charm of like that guerilla filmmaking
like we were saying with the costumes
and the way they shoot it yeah so then
when you do get like these bigger
moments like the car dropping or the VFX
of any
those crazy Star Wars like the walkers
and everything yeah it makes it that
much more rewarding and it stands out
that much more yeah and it still has
this like weird personal touch to it
it feels like my friends made this
exactly this they haven't lost that when
they really they could have at this
stage in the game easily otherwise it'd
be too much of a distance from them and
this still feels like now this is the
rack a rack of people we've grown to
love yeah from the beginning of point of
however many years ago it's been this
because I suck at math so yeah I'm glad
you liked it so worried now I'm gonna
subscribe to them why are you worried
you know women know five things funny
what do you know don't find things funny
anymore yeah everything gets canceled
now
three Todd Phillips I thought you were
gonna camp it was fine until the sex
jokes came in and then no that is a
terrible representation of the kind of
culture no no someone would I'm not
cases cool people who have deep rooted
beliefs can be cool too
whatever why are you making this
political why did you start this you
started guys subscribe to rack a wrecker
subscribe to Casey's Channel blonde
jokes or she does sketches as well
[Laughter]
subscribe to us quick tour notification
bail and I'd like to give a patron the
day shout out to a man named Jay T he's
our handsome Japanese man from Hawaii
he's gonna go watch Gemini man this week
and he just sent me a message and I hope
you enjoy yourselves that was starting
to evolve in my brain and I got ahead of
myself
cuz there's - well Smith's
was gonna make a joke about you know it
would be cool there was like a younger
JT with you as well so there were two
JT's because double the JT is fun just
getting a shout out and that's what
counts
okay buddy don't be mad at me it's
Casey's fault ah women are ruining combo
[Laughter]